many americans feeling more stressed as
interest rates rise again that'll of
course impact home and auto loans but
also credit cards and it's an issue
nevadans are pretty familiar with a
recent self study shows that our state
has the most credit card debt in the
nation sasha loftis joining us now with
more
denise and brian a lot of people are
struggling to make those minimum
payments right now i spoke with a woman
who had to use credit cards to get her
business up and running now she says the
majority of her income goes to paying
them back
i just feel like i'm in kind of like a
debt hole joe schlesinger is dealing
with what she calls a vicious cycle
she opened her business starburst parlor
keto bakery late last year and had to
use her personal credit cards to get
things off the ground so wrap this one
and then put it in the fridge now she's
strapped with overwhelming payments
every month i'm just thinking about what
this credit card bill's due it's 420
minimum how am i going to make this
payment in may the federal reserve bank
of new york said our country is carrying
841 billion dollars in credit card debt
financial advisor mahesh odrani says
inflation and another federal interest
rate hike could make things even harder
they may not have saved up a rainy day
fund
or have a savings account that they can
dip into so where do they go for
additional cash and additional resources
is credit card but he added there are
options
you can transfer what you owe to a zero
balance card or a home equity line of
credit you can also try to negotiate a
lower rate or get help from a credit
counselor it's almost like spinning in a
wheel
that every time i think i'm going to get
ahead i just have another bill that
comes in as for jill she's just doing
her best to stay afloat
and serve the community she loves aside
from like a dream or winning the lottery
there's no end to it
now adrani says debt consolidation
companies are also an option but he said
you have to be careful make sure to pick
a program that focuses on lowering your
debt without missing payments and
keeping your credit score intact